as we move forward together we get that
right results for our country but this
is about our country it is about our
national interest as I say everybody
won't have to I'll give a one-on-one one
last time I'll give way to honorable
lady thank the Prime Minister for giving
way the Prime Minister's say this is
about the country but with respect Prime
Minister but she's not how its seen
brexit withdraw our agreement referendum
has always been about the Conservative
Party
[Applause]
this this house this house across all
parties voted for a referendum
this house across all parties voted to
trigger article
sorry I'm so sorry I forget of course at
the Scottish National Party always have
a different view on this because they
want to stay in the EU they want to stay
in the Common Agricultural Policy they
want to stay in the Common Fisheries
no good no good for Scottish no good for
Scottish fishermen and Scottish farmers
I had I had said I would give one last
time because I just reference the SMP
I'm a waiter
well it's some way to build compromise
mr. speaker but why did she never come
forward to the Scottish Government and
Scottish National Party offer wide
sweeping reforms and devolution for
employment law on welfare for example in
order to give Scotland the pirate needs
to protect itself from the measures in
her deal that it doesn't like instead
she stuck her head in the sand and
that's why she's got nowhere with the
Scottish government or the Scottish
National Party honourable gentlemen the
government has given the Scottish
government extra powers and they're not
using
except except except of course the power
to increase taxes so I say to members
this if you want to deliver brexit this
is the moment if you're passionate about
making sure that the United Kingdom
leaves the European Union backed this
motion if you care about our union and
it wants a deal that protects it back
the motion if you want to honor the
referendum but want Parliament to shape
our future relationship back this motion
it's the right thing for our country
it's the right thing for our
constituents and with all my heart I
commend this motion to the house
[Music]
the question is as on the order paper as
many as other Davidian say aye
of the country now
[Applause]
little baby
[Music]
[Music]
or the question is as on the order paper
as many as are 30 billion say I of the
country now tell us for the eyes and
drew Stevenson and crave Whitaker tell
us for the nose thing um debonair and
Nick taken
lock the doors
[Music]
[Applause]
order order the eyes to the right 286
the nose to the left 344
[Applause]
the eyes to the right 286 the nose to
the left 344
so the noes have it the noes have it
unlock point of order the Prime Minister
Mr Speaker I think it should be a matter
of profound regret to every member of
this house the once again we have been
unable to support leaving the European
the implications of the houses decision
are grave the legal default now is that
United Kingdom is due to leave the
European Union on the 12th of April in
just 14 days time that is not enough
time to agree legislate for and ratify a
deal and yet to the house has been clear
it will not permit leaving without a
deal
and so we would have to agree an
alternative way forward the European
Union has been clear that any further
extension will need to have a clear foot
purpose and will need to be agreed
unanimously by the heads of the other 27
member states ahead of the 12th of April
it is almost certain to involve the
United Kingdom being required to hold
European parliamentary elections
on Monday on Monday this house will
continue the process to see if there is
a stable majority for a particular
alternative version of our future
relationship with the EU of course all
of the options will require the
withdrawal agreement
Mr Speaker I fear we are reaching the
limits of this process in this house
this house this house has rejected No
Deal
it has rejected no brexit on Wednesday
it rejected all the variations of the
deal on the table and today it has
rejected approving the withdrawal
agreement alone and continuing a process
on the future this government will
continue to press the case for the
orderly brexit that the result of the
referendum demands
mr. jeremy corbyn on a point of order
mr. speaker this is now the third time
the Prime Minister's deal has been
rejected what he was defeated the first
time the Prime Minister said it's clear
this house does not support the deal
does she now finally accept that the
house does not support the deal because
she seemed to indicate just now that
she's going to return to this issue
again on Monday this house has the
chance and I say to all members mr.
speaker the responsibility to find a
majority for a better deal
for all the people of this country mr.
speaker the house has been clear this
deal now has to change there has to be
an alternative found and if the Prime
Minister can't accept that then she must
go not at an indeterminate date in the
future but now so that we can decide the
future of this country through a general
election
boy to order mystery and blackbird
[Music]
thank you Thank You mr. speakers Thank
You mr. speaker we should all be aware
they right honourable gentlemen must be
heard mr. Ian Blackford Thank You mr.
speaker we should all be aware of the
responsibilities that we all have in
this house the seriousness of the
situation that we are in and I would say
respectfully to the Prime Minister she
now has to accept the her deal has been
defeated three times and and I applaud
the members of parliament on all sides
that voted against the government's
proposition it is a bad deal and we have
defined a way out of the crisis that we
are in all of our constituents would
expect that we meet we must give our
sales time and I suggest to the prime
minister we know must look seriously at
the option of relocation we need to
apply the handbrake to this process and
quite simply mr. speaker the Prime
Minister has failed to take this deal
forward she does not have the confidence
of the house the Prime Minister has
indicated her departure she should know
door and we should be having a general
election some instant cable on Monday it
is perfectly possible that the house may
indicate a preference for one of the
options such as a customs union or a
confirmatory vote which are of course
compatible with withdrawal agreement if
that is the case is the Prime Minister
then open to listening to the view of
the house and considering how we might
have a longer extension to explore them
I think the question was perhaps to some
degree a rhetorical inquiry the right
honourable gentleman has made his point
but further debate on these important
matters will follow next week and we'll
leave it there the point water Heidi
Allen the prime minister must now
seriously recognize this deal is over
and this house has a responsibility a
serious responsibility on Monday to find
a solution to this impasse there are
jobs and livelihoods right across this
country at the stake now as many of us
have been saying for months and months
and months we must have a people's vote
now
we know Lord yes I will come to the
Honorable lady first because I saw her
first point of order
Carolina Lucas Thank You mr. speaker I
mean it does beg a belief that the Prime
Minister still seems to not recognize a
dead deal when there's one right in
front of her it has now been defeated
three times and that is in spite of the
procedural games that have been played
and that she realized just how grotesque
it looked when frankly she was looking
as if she was willing to sell out the
country's future for the price of some
Tory MP careers in replacement for it
the idea that it was somehow sensible
for MPs on the other side to say that
they would suddenly change their minds
about a deal they've been against for
months because they thought they might
have some career advantage from it
there is a degree of latitude on these
occasions but the Honourable lady has
stretched it excessively if she wanted
to speak in the debate she might well
have caught my eye but she didn't seek
to do so have points of order mr. Nigel
dogs speaker could I urge the prime
minister and I to look seriously of what
the right honourable gentleman the
number 4 issuer and Walton said earlier
in the course of the debate avoid the
backstop issues she knows
that remains the problem she knows that
Michel Barnier and Li Oviraptor this
week have said in New Deal scenario
there will be no hard border please
Prime Minister even now as the right
honourable gentleman said earlier use
the time constructively to get that
matter shorted I'd invite the whip on
duty to move this house do now adjourn
another Wednesday I
don't you know I think the eyes have it
the eyes have it order order
you